-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
"This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing
well tonight.
And, now, let's get to the news.
The Biden administration
today ordered
U.S. companies
with 100 or more employees
to have their workers fully
vaccinated or regularly tested
for the coronavirus
by January 4th.
Alright!
You heard the man,
Arcade Fire.
[ Laughter ]
And we're off!
New Jersey Governor Phil Murphy
won reelection last night,
making him the first Democrat
in 44 years
to be sentenced
to a second term.
[ Laughter ]
Despite telling reporters
earlier this year
that he'd been immunized,
Green Bay quarterback
Aaron Rodgers
reportedly received
a homeopathic treatment
from his personal doctor
to raise his antibody levels,
instead of getting
the coronavirus vaccine.
Dude, that's an immunization
the same way this
is a ponytail.
[ Laughter ]
It's not.
According to a new report,
Dominion Voting Systems'
$1.3 billion defamation lawsuit
against MyPillow CEO
Mike Lindell could result
in Dominion owning
the pillow company,
but they're not interested
because the voting booths
are more comfortable.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Dominion could
end up owning MyPillow.
Wow. If that happens, I hope
they keep the Dominion name.
Dominion would be a badass name
for a pillow company.
[ Laughter ]
Dominion Pillows.
You will sleep, loser!
[ Laughter ]
A new study suggests men
feel more heartbroken than women
after a breakup.
The study is entitled...
[ Laughter and ohs ]
In honor of the
"Sex and the City" reboot,
Airbnb will offer guests
a chance to stay
at a recreation of Carrie's
apartment for $23 per night.
Or, for just $10,
Steve will come over
and hang at your place.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Steve ]
Hey, thanks so much
for having me over.
Miranda and I
are having a fight.
It's so good.
It's such a good Steve.
[ Laughter ]
Finally, today was rapper
and entrepreneur
Sean P. "Diddy" Combs'
52nd birthday.
He celebrated the same way
he always does --
in line at the notary
public's office,
getting his name
legally changed.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!